- Bem-vindo de volta a Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation.
Meu nome é John Watrous e sou o diretor técnico
do IBM Quantum Education.
Esta é a terceira aula da série. Nas primeiras duas aulas, falamos sobre os fundamentos
da informação quântica.
Primeiro para sistemas únicos isolados e depois para múltiplos sistemas.
Também discutimos medições de base padrão e operações unitárias em ambos os contextos
de sistema único e múltiplos sistemas.
Nesta aula, vamos introduzir
o modelo de circuit quântico, que nos oferece uma maneira padrão de descrever computações quânticas,
e também podemos usar circuits quânticos para descrever protocolos quânticos e outros tipos de interações envolvendo múltiplos dispositivos quânticos.
Além dos circuits quânticos, também vamos discutir alguns
importantes conceitos matemáticos conectados com informação quântica,
e vamos usá-los para observar
algumas limitações fundamentais na informação quântica e no que podemos fazer com circuits quânticos.
Isso vai nos preparar bem para
a aula seguinte, onde veremos alguns
exemplos muito importantes e isso concluirá a
primeira unidade da série
sobre os fundamentos da informação quântica.
Aqui está uma visão geral da aula. Vamos começar com o modelo de circuit quântico e ver como ele funciona.
Depois vamos falar sobre a
noção criticamente importante de produto interno, bem como ortogonalidade e projeções,
que estão conectadas com produtos internos. Não discutimos essas coisas
nas primeiras duas aulas porque realmente não
precisávamos, mas agora precisamos.
Os produtos internos nos fornecem
uma ferramenta matemática sem a qual simplesmente não poderíamos trabalhar.
Simplesmente não avançaríamos muito em compreender a informação quântica e
a computação sem produtos internos.
E na terceira parte da aula, vamos dar uma olhada em
algumas limitações importantes da informação quântica.
Em última análise, o que queremos é explorar coisas interessantes que podemos fazer com a informação quântica, mas para fazer isso efetivamente,
precisamos estar cientes de algumas
coisas que não podemos fazer.
Em particular, vamos discutir
a noção de fase global e por que as fases globais são irrelevantes.
Vamos ver um enunciado do
teorema da não-clonagem, que nos diz que estados quânticos não podem ser copiados em geral, e vamos ver que dois estados quânticos
não podem ser perfeitamente
discriminados um do outro a menos que sejam ortogonais, o que é uma limitação fundamental a se ter em mente.
O primeiro tópico da aula
é o modelo de circuit quântico, que é um modelo de computação
que nos oferece uma maneira
de descrever computações quânticas.
O modelo de circuit quântico é
baseado em uma noção mais geral em ciência da computação de circuit, e você pode definir muitos
modelos diferentes de computação
com base nessa noção geral.
A ideia básica é que um
circuit é composto de fios que carregam informação, e gates, que representam operações
que são aplicadas à
informação carregada pelos fios.
O termo circuit é na verdade
um nome um tanto estranho para usar para esse tipo de modelo
porque a palavra circuit
geralmente se refere a um
caminho circular de algum tipo.
Mas quando falamos sobre circuits
como modelos de computação, geralmente estamos falando
sobre circuits acíclicos
onde caminhos circulares não são permitidos.
Para ser mais preciso, para os
fins desta série, vamos exigir que
a informação sempre flua da esquerda para a direita em qualquer circuit.
Então, se preferir, você
pode pensar sobre circuits como descrevendo sequências de operações onde o tempo vai da esquerda para a direita.
Aqui está um exemplo de um circuit Booleano onde os fios carregam valores binários, ou zero ou um,
e os gates representam
operações de lógica Booleana.
Os fios são representados por linhas, e aqui temos dois bits de entrada rotulados X e Y,
e se quisermos saber
o que o circuit faz para uma escolha particular de entradas, propagamos os valores nos
fios da esquerda para a direita,
dependendo das ações
que os gates têm sobre os valores que são
carregados pelos fios.
Então, por exemplo, podemos
dar uma olhada no que acontece quando começamos com o fio de entrada superior definido como valor um e o fio de entrada inferior
definido como valor zero.
Esses dois fios de entrada levam
a esses dois pontos aqui, que representam operações de fan-out, o que significa que o valor é copiado
para que possa ser carregado
adiante em múltiplos fios.
Então, se fizermos isso, esses
dois fios assumem o valor um, que é o mesmo que este aqui, e esses dois fios assumem o valor zero,
que é o mesmo que este aqui.
Aqui temos um gate NOT que
é indicado pelo símbolo de negação lógica, portanto o
valor que sai é zero,
que é a negação lógica de um. E de forma semelhante, o valor
que sai desse gate é um, que é a
negação lógica de zero.
Esses dois gates são gates AND,
esse gate é um gate OR, e se continuarmos
e propagarmos os valores
pelo circuit, avaliando
os gates apropriadamente, então vemos que o valor final
nesse fio aqui é um.
Então o circuit inteiro descreve
uma sequência de operações que são compostas como a figura sugere, e acabamos com uma função
de dois bits para um bit
neste caso particular. Mas em geral, poderia haver qualquer número
de bits de entrada e saída.
Este circuit em particular calcula o OU exclusivo dos dois bits de entrada, portanto a saída é um
se e somente se exatamente
um dos dois bits de entrada estiver definido como um e o outro estiver definido como zero, mas isso não é realmente
importante, é apenas um exemplo.
É um fato básico sobre circuits Booleanos que qualquer função de qualquer número de bits para qualquer número de bits pode ser calculada
por algum circuit Booleano, embora às vezes você possa
precisar de um circuit muito grande para calcular a função
em que está interessado.
Há outros estilos que
são usados para descrever circuits.
Por exemplo, esta figura
representa exatamente o mesmo circuit que tínhamos antes, usando um estilo que é talvez mais típico
em engenharia elétrica, onde há convenções para as formas que representam diferentes gates.
Não vamos usar
esse estilo particular, mas vamos introduzir
alguns símbolos nossos para diferentes gates quânticos, como gates Hadamard,
gates Controlled NOT,
gates Toffoli e assim por diante.
Só como curiosidade, aqui podemos ver a origem
do termo circuit.
No contexto da engenharia elétrica, é muito natural
pensar sobre eletricidade circulando por um circuit.
Mas nesta série, não estamos
falando sobre eletricidade movendo-se por circuits, estamos falando sobre informação
movendo-se por circuits.
E mais uma vez para nós, eles serão sempre acíclicos, onde a informação
se move da esquerda para a direita.
Aqui está um exemplo diferente de
um tipo diferente de circuit chamado circuit aritmético.
Desta vez, os fios armazenam números e os gates representam
operações aritméticas como adição e multiplicação.
Aqui você pode ver um exemplo
de um circuit aritmético.
Não é importante para esta
aula o que ele faz, é apenas um exemplo que
visa transmitir a ideia de que há diferentes
noções de circuits.
Também podemos pensar sobre
circuits envolvendo aleatoriedade, por exemplo, onde os gates representam
operações probabilísticas, e se quisesse,
você poderia provavelmente ficar o dia inteiro inventando novos modelos de computação baseados na noção de circuits.
No modelo de circuit quântico,
os fios representam qubits, e os gates representam tanto operações unitárias quanto medições.
Aqui está um exemplo muito simples
de um circuit quântico.
Há apenas um qubit neste circuit, que é representado
pela linha horizontal, e os gates, que são
indicados por quadrados,
representam operações unitárias que são realizadas neste qubit.
Então não há medições
neste exemplo em particular.
Se quisermos dar ao
qubit um nome como X, podemos indicar isso no diagrama colocando um X aqui mesmo, isso é opcional.
Assim como tínhamos para o circuit Booleano de alguns momentos atrás, podemos pensar sobre este circuit
como representando uma sequência de operações onde o tempo
vai da esquerda para a direita.
Então começamos com X,
aplicamos o primeiro gate, que é um gate Hadamard
seguido de um gate S,
depois outro gate Hadamard
e finalmente um gate T.
Vimos essas operações
perto do fim da aula um, e aqui você pode ver
suas descrições matriciais.
Então, quando realizamos essas
quatro operações em ordem, o que significa primeiro H, depois
S, depois H novamente e depois T,
a operação combinada é dada
por este produto aqui, tendo em mente que a ordem
essencialmente se inverte
como discutimos na aula um. Se realizarmos a multiplicação matricial, obtemos esta matriz aqui,
e assim a ação do
circuit no qubit X é descrita por esta matriz unitária.
Às vezes gostaríamos de indicar explicitamente em um diagrama de circuit quântico
qual entrada estamos fornecendo, e podemos fazer isso como você vê aqui.
Neste caso, estamos inserindo
Ket 0 no circuit.
Isso é bastante comum. Frequentemente tomamos Ket 0 como
o estado inicializado de um qubit, mas isso não é necessário.
Poderíamos também considerar
aplicar o circuit a um estado diferente.
Se escolhermos, também podemos
indicar o estado de saída que obtemos assim.
Aqui está outro exemplo onde
desta vez temos dois qubits chamados X e Y como você
pode ver no diagrama.
Aqui temos um gate Hadamard, que está sendo aplicado ao qubit Y, seguido pelo gate indicado por
este símbolo aqui,
que é um gate Controlled NOT. Falamos sobre a operação
Controlled NOT na aula anterior,
e aqui neste diagrama podemos
ver que o qubit de controle é Y, que é indicado pelo
pequeno círculo preenchido,
e o qubit alvo é X, que é indicado pelo círculo grande com o que parece um sinal de mais dentro.
Parece um pouco com o
símbolo de OU exclusivo, então faz sentido.
Você pode imaginar que qualquer
estado clássico armazenado em Y é aplicado via XOR no qubit X.
E só por clareza, aqui está o diagrama que
mostra a ação desse gate em estados de base padrão,
onde assumimos que A
e B são valores binários.
Para outros estados, a ação é determinada
pela linearidade como sempre.
Agora, antes de prosseguirmos, será útil
enunciar explicitamente uma convenção que vamos seguir sobre como os qubits são ordenados
em diagramas de circuit quântico como este.
E a convenção é que
a ordem de baixo para cima em um diagrama de circuit quântico é equivalente à ordem da esquerda para a direita
como em uma tupla ou um produto tensorial.
Essa é uma convenção que vamos
seguir na série e também é a convenção
usada no Qiskit.
Então, para este circuit específico aqui, estamos pensando sobre ele como
atuando em um par de qubits X, Y,
X vem primeiro porque está na parte inferior, e Y vem por último ou segundo neste caso, porque está no topo.
A maneira de pensar sobre isso visualmente, caso ajude, é imaginar rotacionar
este circuit no sentido horário para que as entradas estejam no topo
e as saídas estejam na parte inferior, e a ordem dos
qubits estará correta.
Às vezes essa ordem confunde as pessoas, então certifique-se de manter
essa convenção em mente.
Então, quando pensamos sobre a ação que este circuit descreve, o que temos primeiro é um gate Hadamard aplicado a Y
e depois um gate Controlled NOT
nos dois qubits com Y sendo o controle
e X sendo o alvo.
Se quisermos escrever uma matriz unitária que descreve a ação combinada
desses dois gates, podemos fazer isso.
Primeiro, consideramos o gate Hadamard em Y.
Estamos aplicando o gate Hadamard a Y e não fazendo nada com X, o que é equivalente a
realizar uma operação identidade em X.
E assim a ação do gate Hadamard em ambos os qubits juntos é
dada pelo produto tensorial da matriz identidade e
da matriz representando
a operação Hadamard em Y.
Parece com isso, tendo em mente nossa
convenção de que X vem primeiro e Y vem segundo, então é
a identidade tensoriada com H.
Depois aplicamos a
operação Controlled NOT, que tem esta representação matricial, e isso novamente é consistente com nossa convenção.
O segundo qubit Y é o controle e o primeiro qubit X é o alvo.
Não tenha medo de pausar o vídeo e verificar se isso faz sentido, e vou parar de te lembrar disso.
Você pode pausar esses vídeos, voltar e assistir partes
quantas vezes quiser, ajustar a velocidade de reprodução se quiser, usá-los da
maneira que funcionar melhor para você.
De qualquer forma, quando componemos as
duas operações juntas, a ação combinada é descrita
por este produto aqui,
e essas duas matrizes são
multiplicadas nessa ordem porque o Hadamard é realizado primeiro e o Controlled NOT
é realizado segundo,
e isso novamente é consistente
com o que discutimos na aula um onde a ordem
essencialmente se inverte.
Se realizarmos a multiplicação matricial, obtemos esta matriz aqui.
E podemos agora ler desta matriz o que o circuit faz com os
estados de base padrão.
Se executarmos o circuit na entrada 0, 0, ou seja, Ket 0 para o primeiro qubit, Ket 0 para o segundo qubit,
o resultado é o estado Bell Phi+, que podemos ver na
primeira coluna da matriz.
Se inserirmos 0, 1, obtemos o estado Phi-, e um zero nos dá o estado Si+,
e 1, 1 nos dá não Psi-, mas -1 vezes Psi-.
O sinal de menos não é
realmente significativo aqui. Se não quisesse que este estivesse aqui, você poderia realizar uma operação de swap
nos dois qubits
para se livrar dele e você
não estragaria o que aconteceu com os três primeiros estados de base padrão.
Mas isso não é realmente importante
para fins deste exemplo.
Então, em resumo, o circuit tem esta ação aqui nos estados de base padrão.
Quando você está pensando sobre
o que um circuit específico faz, não precisa passar pela
conversão para matrizes e multiplicá-las,
você também pode traçar a
ação que o circuit tem sobre estados específicos, e em muitos casos esta será
a opção preferida.
Neste exemplo, por exemplo, podemos ver o que o circuit
faz com o estado 0, 0 examinando a ação dos gates.
O estado inicial, que
chamamos de Pi zero aqui, apenas para evitar um nome
que seria confundido com os estados Bell, é 0, 0.
Aplicamos o gate Hadamard e o estado que obtemos é 0+ que podemos expandir assim,
e então a operação Controlled NOT leva esse estado ao estado Phi+, que podemos ver pensando
sobre a ação que o Controlled NOT tem sobre os
estados de base padrão,
E você pode fazer a mesma
coisa para os outros três estados de base padrão ou qualquer
outro estado.
Também podemos incorporar bits clássicos em diagramas de circuit quântico.
Eles são indicados por
linhas duplas como você vê neste diagrama.
Ou seja, A e B são bits clássicos e X e Y são qubits.
Temos os mesmos dois gates unitários do exemplo anterior, e estes símbolos aqui representam medições de base padrão
Especificamente, depois que as duas
operações unitárias são realizadas, uma medição de base padrão
é realizada em Y
e o resultado é sobrescrito
no bit clássico B, e de forma semelhante X é medido e o resultado é escrito no bit A.
Aqui você pode ver que os qubits X e Y continuam depois de serem medidos.
É bastante comum
que não nos importemos muito com qubits
após serem medidos.
Às vezes tudo o que nos importa
é o resultado da medição. E num caso assim, podemos usar o estilo abreviado que você vê aqui
onde as medições têm qubits entrando e bits clássicos saindo.
O entendimento aqui é que
uma vez que os qubits são medidos, eles são simplesmente descartados ou ignorados e o resultado clássico da medição
é levado adiante.
Agora, à medida que a série continua, vamos ver muitos
exemplos de circuits quânticos e eles tipicamente
serão muito mais complicados do que os exemplos muito simples que acabamos de ver.
Como mencionei anteriormente, diferentes símbolos são
usados para diferentes gates.
Gates de qubit único geralmente
são apenas escritos como quadrados com uma letra indicando
qual operação é.
Às vezes esses diferentes
gates são codificados por cores para significar coisas diferentes, mas
vamos ignorar isso por enquanto.
Já vimos o
gate Controlled NOT.
Gates swap são denotados
como você vê aqui, e gates Toffoli e Fredkin
são denotados como você vê aqui.
Lembre-se de que um gate Toffoli é um gate controlled Controlled NOT e um gate Fredkin é
um gate controlled swap.
Então esses símbolos são
consistentes com a ideia de que um qubit de controle é
indicado por um círculo sólido com uma linha conectando-o
ao gate que controla.
Em geral, qubits de controle
não precisam estar no topo e esses gates não precisam
atuar em qubits vizinhos, o que significa que esses gates
podem se estender
sobre outros qubits nos quais não atuam, e vamos ver isso
em aulas futuras.
Mais uma coisa que frequentemente fazemos ao usar o modelo de circuit quântico é ver operações unitárias arbitrárias
em qualquer número de qubits
como se fossem gates únicos como você vê aqui.
Apenas desenhando um retângulo com um rótulo correspondendo
a qualquer operação unitária que seja.
Neste caso, é alguma
operação unitária U.
Claro, não sabemos
o que é U a partir deste diagrama, temos que assumir que
U é definido de alguma forma ou que estamos considerando alguma
operação unitária U arbitrária, talvez. Poderia ser, por exemplo, que
simplesmente queiramos pensar sobre U como se fosse uma sub-rotina no interesse da clareza.
Também usamos essa notação
que você vê aqui para uma operação U controlada
onde o qubit de controle é indicado por um círculo sólido
assim como tínhamos antes.
Então essa é uma breve introdução
ao modelo de circuit quântico. E como disse antes, veremos muitos mais
exemplos de circuits quânticos
à medida que continuamos na série.
Na próxima parte da aula, vamos dar uma
olhada em produtos internos, ortonormalidade e projeções, que são noções muito importantes
em informação e computação quântica.
Vamos começar com produtos internos.
Lembre-se de que quando
usamos a notação Dirac, um ket é um vetor coluna
e um bra é um vetor linha,
e especificamente o vetor
bra correspondente a um dado vetor coluna é a transposta conjugada
desse vetor coluna.
Então, para este vetor aqui, obtemos o vetor bra correspondente transpondo o vetor
como se fosse uma matriz,
o que equivale a deitá-lo de lado e depois tomar o conjugado complexo de cada uma das entradas.
Agora suponha que temos dois kets com o mesmo número de entradas como este.
Se formarmos esse bracket aqui, que simplesmente significa que
tomamos o produto do bra e do ket,
como se fossem matrizes,
então obtemos esta expressão
que você vê aqui, que é um escalar, ou em
outras palavras, um número complexo.
Esse valor é chamado de produto interno
desses dois vetores.
Você também pode pensar sobre produtos internos em termos de vetores da
forma que você vê aqui, onde os vetores são expressos
como combinações lineares
de vetores de base padrão.
O produto interno desses vetores é definido da mesma maneira que
antes, bra Psi vezes ket Phi que podemos expressar
como um produto assim.
E se calcularmos e simplificarmos, ficamos com esta expressão aqui para o produto interno, que é análogo ao que tínhamos antes,
exceto que desta vez estamos
tomando a soma sobre elementos do nosso conjunto de estado clássico, que é sigma neste caso particular.
Aqui está um exemplo que visa dar uma imagem geométrica de
como os produtos internos funcionam.
Aqui desenhei um círculo
em um espaço bidimensional correspondendo a um qubit, e enquanto restringirmos nossa atenção
a vetores com entradas de números reais, podemos desenhá-los como pontos neste plano.
Vamos tomar Phi como sendo
este vetor aqui.
É um vetor unitário, o que podemos ver calculando a norma euclidiana e é isso que esse círculo representa,
são todos os vetores unitários
com entradas de números reais.
Vamos também dizer que Psi é
este vetor aqui, que também é um vetor unitário.
É o estado menos de fato, mas aqui simplesmente o chamamos de Psi.
Se calcularmos o produto interno
desses dois vetores, obtemos um menos a raiz quadrada de três sobre dois vezes raiz de dois,
que é aproximadamente -1/4.
O valor desse produto interno é igual ao cosseno do ângulo
entre os dois vetores, que você pode ver aqui na figura.
Isso é algo que é
geralmente verdadeiro para vetores unitários. Se tivermos dois vetores unitários e ambos tiverem entradas de números reais,
então o produto interno entre eles é igual ao cosseno do
ângulo entre eles.
Em particular, se o produto interno
é igual a zero, como neste exemplo, onde mudamos Psi para
ser este estado aqui,
então os dois vetores devem
estar em um ângulo de 90 graus um com o outro.
Isso tudo se generaliza para
vetores em qualquer dimensão, aliás, desde que as
entradas sejam números reais, não é apenas para vetores bidimensionais.
Se tivermos entradas de números complexos, a imagem não funciona mais, mas mesmo assim, o produto interno é igualmente
útil como veremos.
O produto interno tem algumas
propriedades muito importantes e vamos levar alguns momentos para observar algumas dessas propriedades agora.
Primeiro é uma conexão
entre o produto interno e a norma euclidiana.
Se tomarmos o produto interno
de qualquer vetor com ele mesmo, obtemos a norma euclidiana ao quadrado.
Então, alternativamente, podemos dizer que a norma euclidiana de um vetor é igual à raiz quadrada do produto interno
desse vetor com ele mesmo. Isso não é uma coincidência, é
uma conexão fundamental, e aqui podemos ver que se não tivéssemos
os conjugados complexos na definição do produto interno, então essa fórmula
não seria verdadeira, e não teríamos uma noção tão útil
com essa conexão fundamental
com a norma euclidiana.
Em seguida, o produto interno
é conjugado simétrico, o que significa que se trocamos
a ordem dos dois argumentos, então o valor que obtemos para o
produto interno fica conjugado.
Isso é expresso por
esta equação aqui e é bastante direto ver por que isso acontece para essas duas expressões
para o produto interno dos dois vetores nas duas ordens possíveis.
O produto interno é linear
no segundo argumento. Especificamente, se definirmos um vetor Phi como sendo esta combinação linear de dois vetores,
Phi um e Phi dois, então o produto interno de
qualquer vetor Psi com Phi é a mesma combinação linear
dos dois produtos internos,
e isso segue bastante
diretamente do fato de que a multiplicação matricial é linear.
E também temos que o produto interno é conjugado linear no primeiro argumento, que você pode ver expresso aqui.
Se Psi é esta combinação linear de vetores, então se tomarmos o produto
interno de Psi e Phi,
então bra Psi se torna este vetor que vemos aqui onde tomamos o conjugado complexo de beta um e beta dois,
e assim este é o resultado e é isso que se quer dizer
por linearidade conjugada.
E a última propriedade do produto interno que quero mencionar é
a incrivelmente útil desigualdade de Cauchy-Schwarz.
Para quaisquer dois vetores, Psi e Phi, o valor absoluto do produto interno nunca pode ser maior que o
produto das normas euclidianas
dos dois vetores. E além disso, a única maneira de que os dois
lados da desigualdade podem ser iguais é se os dois
vetores são linearmente dependentes,
o que significa que um deles é igual a algum escalar vezes o outro.
Esta é na verdade uma das
desigualdades mais amplamente usadas em toda a matemática e
a usamos repetidamente ao falar sobre
informação quântica,
então é muito bom conhecê-la.
Em seguida, vamos falar sobre as
noções de ortogonalidade e ortonormalidade que estão
conectadas com produtos internos
e especificamente, com
produtos internos de vetores sendo iguais a zero.
Para ser preciso, se temos
dois vetores, Psi e Phi, dizemos que são ortogonais
se seu produto interno
é igual a zero. E a maneira de pensar
sobre vetores ortogonais intuitivamente é que eles estão
em ângulos retos entre si,
ou alternativamente, que são
perpendiculares um ao outro.
As pessoas às vezes usam o termo ortogonal para se referir a coisas que não têm
nada a ver com cada uma, como dizer que uma questão
é ortogonal a outra,
mas isso é obviamente bastante informal e não realmente significativo
em sentido matemático, mas a conexão é clara se você pensar sobre vetores ortogonais como apontando
não em direções opostas, mas em direções completamente diferentes, como norte versus oeste, por exemplo.
Se temos um conjunto de vetores, dizemos que o conjunto é um conjunto ortogonal se quaisquer dois vetores distintos
escolhidos desse conjunto
são necessariamente ortogonais entre si, o que podemos expressar
como você vê aqui,
Um conjunto ortonormal é
simplesmente um conjunto ortogonal de vetores unitários.
Vetores em conjuntos ortogonais
não precisam necessariamente ser vetores unitários, e na verdade você poderia
até ter o vetor zero
como elemento de um conjunto ortogonal, mas em um conjunto ortonormal, todo vetor deve ser um vetor unitário
além do requisito de que o conjunto seja um conjunto ortogonal.
Dado o que sabemos sobre a relação entre o produto interno
e a norma euclidiana, podemos expressar esta
condição de forma bastante sucinta
como você vê aqui.
E finalmente, uma base ortonormal é simplesmente um conjunto ortonormal
que forma uma base para qualquer espaço vetorial
do qual estamos falando.
Por exemplo, se tomarmos qualquer
conjunto de estados clássicos sigma e pensarmos sobre o conjunto de
todos os vetores de base padrão,
vemos que este é um conjunto ortonormal e de fato é uma base ortonormal para o espaço de todos os vetores cujas entradas correspondem a
este conjunto de estados clássicos sigma.
Esses são todos vetores unitários e
são ortogonais em pares, então é um conjunto ortonormal.
e porque também é uma base, temos que é uma base ortonormal.
Conjuntos ortonormais são
sempre linearmente independentes, aliás, então sempre que você
tem um conjunto ortonormal, ele sempre será uma base ortonormal para algum subespaço,
mas neste caso, temos uma base para todo o espaço com o qual estamos trabalhando.
Outro exemplo é o conjunto
contendo Ket+ e Ket-.
Esses dois vetores são ortogonais, seu produto interno é igual a zero.
e ambos são vetores unitários e formam o
espaço bidimensional de vetores correspondendo a um qubit único, então eles formam uma base ortonormal
para esse espaço.
Outro exemplo é a base Bell, que é uma base ortonormal para o espaço de todos
os vetores de quatro dimensões correspondendo a dois qubits.
O conjunto contendo Ket 0
e Ket+, por outro lado, não é um conjunto ortogonal porque o produto interno entre
esses vetores é não nulo.
Ambos são vetores unitários e este é uma base para o espaço vetorial correspondendo a um qubit, mas não temos ortogonalidade.
Aqui está um fato útil sobre conjuntos ortonormais que vamos usar de vez em quando.
Suponha que temos algum
conjunto ortonormal de vetores, especificamente, vamos supor
que temos M vetores neste conjunto, Psi um até Psi M,
onde estamos assumindo que esses vetores são retirados de algum
espaço vetorial N dimensional, ou em outras palavras, cada um dos
vetores tem N entradas.
Como já mencionei, conjuntos ortonormais são sempre
linearmente independentes, portanto não pode ser que M seja maior que N,
mas poderia ser que M seja menor que N, e esse é o caso em que
estamos interessados.
E o que o fato afirma é
que se M é menor que N, então sempre é possível
adicionar vetores adicionais
ao conjunto com o qual começamos, a fim de obter uma
base ortonormal para nosso espaço.
Para ser preciso, necessariamente
devem existir vetores Psi M+1 até Psi N para que toda a coleção
forme uma base ortonormal.
Então você nunca pode se meter em um beco sem saída, por assim dizer, escolhendo de alguma forma um
conjunto ortonormal de vetores que não pode ser estendido para
formar uma base ortonormal.
Às vezes você pode simplesmente olhar
para o conjunto com o qual começa e descobrir como estendê-lo para formar uma base ortonormal, mas uma alternativa que sempre funciona
é usar um procedimento conhecido como processo de ortonormalização de Gram-Schmidt
para construir esses vetores.
Não vou explicar esse
procedimento nesta aula ou nesta série porque os detalhes específicos não são
realmente importantes para nós, mas claro que você pode pesquisar
se estiver curioso.
É algo que pode
ser realizado por um computador, caso seja relevante, então
não há criatividade envolvida, é apenas um procedimento mecânico.
Uma das razões pelas quais este é um fato tão útil de ter é relacionada a uma conexão estreita que existe entre bases ortonormais
e matrizes unitárias.
Em particular, para qualquer matriz quadrada U, as três condições que você vê aqui são sempre equivalentes,
o que significa que elas são
todas verdadeiras ou todas falsas.
A primeira condição diz
que U é uma matriz unitária, o que significa que tanto U dagger vezes U quanto U vezes U dagger são ambas
iguais à matriz identidade.
A segunda condição
diz que as linhas de U formam uma base ortonormal
e a terceira condição diz que as colunas de U
formam uma base ortonormal.
Na verdade não é muito difícil
ver por que essa equivalência é verdadeira.
Só para simplificar, vamos dar uma olhada em uma matriz U três por três como você vê aqui, onde as entradas podem ser quaisquer
números complexos que você quiser.
Aqui no lado esquerdo escrevi U conjugado transposto
apenas por conveniência.
Se formarmos três vetores
das colunas de U, que aqui são chamados Psi
um, Psi dois e Psi três, então se tomarmos o
produto de U dagger e U,
você pode verificar que cada
entrada do produto é dada por um produto interno de vetores como vemos aqui neste padrão.
E agora, quando você pensa sobre a condição de que U é unitária, que é equivalente a essa matriz sendo igual à matriz identidade,
você vê que é equivalente
a que os três vetores formem um conjunto ortonormal.
As entradas diagonais todas
têm que ser iguais a um, então esses são necessariamente vetores unitários, e as entradas fora da diagonal têm que ser zero,
então é um conjunto ortogonal de vetores.
Então U sendo unitária é equivalente a que as colunas formem um conjunto ortonormal,
E isso tem que ser uma base porque o número de vetores no conjunto, que é três neste caso, concorda com a dimensão do espaço
com o qual estamos trabalhando. Você pode seguir um argumento semelhante para as linhas em vez das colunas para concluir que U sendo
unitária é equivalente
a que as linhas formem uma base ortonormal.
Não funciona tão bem porque temos que fazer um ajuste para que os conjugados complexos funcionem da maneira certa, mas a ideia é a mesma.
Uma maneira alternativa de proceder, que é bastante direta, é provar que uma matriz é unitária se e somente se sua transposta é unitária.
E aqui realmente quero dizer transposta e não transposta conjugada.
É bastante trivial a partir da
definição de matrizes unitárias que a transposta conjugada
de qualquer matriz unitária é unitária,
mas também é o caso de que a transposta de qualquer matriz unitária é unitária.
Em qualquer caso, temos a
equivalência entre essas três condições em qualquer matriz quadrada U, e podemos combinar essa equivalência
com o fato sobre
estender conjuntos ortonormais para formar bases ortonormais, a fim de criar matrizes unitárias
que fazem coisas interessantes
ou satisfazem várias necessidades que possamos encontrar.
Especificamente, sempre que
temos um conjunto ortonormal de M vetores, sempre existirá uma matriz unitária U
cujas primeiras M colunas são os vetores desse conjunto ortonormal.
As colunas restantes
sempre podem ser preenchidas para que obtenhamos uma matriz unitária escolhendo-as de modo que as colunas formem
uma base ortonormal. Este será um fato bastante
útil de ter à nossa disposição.
E mais um tópico para
esta seção da aula é a noção de projeção.
Diz-se que uma matriz quadrada Pi
é uma projeção ou uma matriz de projeção se as duas propriedades listadas aqui forem ambas verdadeiras.
Este é um Pi maiúsculo, aliás, é uma escolha bastante típica para uma letra usada para denotar uma projeção.
Frequentemente damos esses nomes típicos a objetos como matrizes apenas para torná-los mais fáceis de reconhecer e manter as coisas organizadas,
mas você pode usar qualquer nome que quiser. De qualquer forma, a primeira condição é que Pi é igual à sua própria transposta conjugada.
Em geral, quando temos uma matriz que é igual à sua própria
transposta conjugada, dizemos que é uma matriz Hermitiana.
Então a primeira condição pode ser alternativamente enunciada como Pi é Hermitiana.
A segunda condição é
que se elevarmos Pi ao quadrado, ou seja, se multiplicarmos Pi
por ela mesma, obtemos Pi novamente.
Então elevar Pi ao quadrado não faz nada com ela.
A ideia de uma projeção
intuitivamente falando é que é similar em
espírito a projetar uma imagem numa tela ou traçar
uma perpendicular sobre uma linha,
por exemplo. Quando você multiplica um
vetor por uma projeção, o que está fazendo é em algum sentido
deixar uma parte dele intacta
e zerando o resto.
Então se você aplicar uma
projeção uma segunda vez, ela não faz nada porque
você já zerou a parte que a projeção zera.
Um exemplo de projeção
é esta matriz aqui para qualquer escolha de um vetor unitário Psi.
Podemos verificar que ela satisfaz
as condições necessárias uma por uma.
Para a primeira, calculamos
a transposta conjugada e esta é a transposta conjugada de um produto.
E assim podemos usar esta fórmula aqui para a transposta conjugada
de um produto para nos ajudar.
O que você obtém é o produto
das transpostas conjugadas, mas a ordem é invertida.
Isso acontece por causa
da parte de transposição.
Então se aplicarmos essa fórmula, obtemos esta igualdade aqui e podemos então simplificar para
obter de volta a matriz original.
Note aliás que não usamos o fato
de que Psi é um vetor unitário.
Portanto, na verdade, esta matriz é
Hermitiana para qualquer vetor Psi, não apenas para vetores unitários.
E para a segunda, elevamos Pi ao quadrado e obtemos
esta expressão aqui e isso é igual à
matriz original desta vez
porque Psi é um vetor unitário, portanto este produto interno
aqui é igual a um e é aí que a suposição
de que Psi é um vetor unitário
entra em jogo.
Podemos generalizar este exemplo e começar com um conjunto ortonormal.
E se formarmos esta matriz aqui, onde somamos as projeções correspondentes aos vetores individuais, então obtemos uma projeção.
Aqui na tela, você pode ver os cálculos que revelam isso e vou deixar que você os examine se quiser.
E de maneira semelhante
ao primeiro exemplo, é a segunda condição onde a ortonormalidade
do conjunto é usada.
O que essa projeção faz se
você a multiplica a um vetor, é projetar esse
vetor no subespaço que é gerado por esse conjunto de vetores,
o que, de forma abstrata, é
como traçar uma perpendicular a esse subespaço, e uma vez
que você está nesse subespaço, a projeção não faz nada.
Então matrizes como esta são
exemplos de projeções, e agora na verdade esgotamos
todas as possibilidades.
Toda matriz de projeção tem esta forma para alguma escolha de um conjunto ortonormal.
A matriz zero é uma projeção, então precisamos nos certificar de
que a incluímos se quisermos ter toda projeção.
Então, para ficar claro sobre isso, estamos permitindo a
possibilidade de que M seja igual a zero e isso nos dá uma soma vazia,
que podemos interpretar como a matriz zero.
Agora que temos o
conceito de projeção à nossa disposição, podemos definir uma classe mais geral
de medições quânticas conhecidas como medições projetivas.
Esta não é a noção mais geral
de medição, mas é significativamente mais geral do que medições de base padrão
e vai ser muito
útil incorporá-la à nossa descrição
de informação quântica.
Uma medição projetiva é definida por qualquer conjunto de projeções
que satisfaça a condição que você vê aqui, que é que as projeções
somam a matriz identidade.
Aqui M pode ser qualquer
inteiro positivo que você quiser, desde que essas sejam todas projeções e esta condição seja verdadeira,
a coleção define uma
medição projetiva.
A medição descrita
por tal coleção funciona da seguinte forma quando você
mede qualquer estado quântico Psi.
Primeiro você obtém um resultado
entre um e M, onde M é o número de projeções.
Para cada resultado possível K, a probabilidade de obter esse resultado é a norma euclidiana
ao quadrado do vetor que você obtém
multiplicando S por Pi
K, a K-ésima projeção.
Também podemos escrever esta
quantidade como você vê aqui.
Essa igualdade vem da relação entre a norma euclidiana
e o produto interno junto com o fato
de que Pi K é uma projeção.
Da segunda forma, junto com a condição que temos sobre essas projeções, podemos ver imediatamente, pela linearidade, que nossas probabilidades
sempre somarão um,
tendo em mente que Psi
tem que ser um vetor unitário.
E segundo, assumindo que
obtemos o resultado K, o estado do sistema
colapsa ao estado quântico que obtemos normalizando qualquer
vetor que obtivemos pela projeção.
Vamos dar uma olhada em alguns
exemplos em apenas um momento, mas antes de fazermos isso, deixa eu mencionar que na verdade não precisamos
numerar os resultados possíveis
de um a M. Podemos escolher quaisquer nomes ou símbolos que quisermos para os resultados.
Em particular, se tivermos uma coleção de projeções que são rotuladas com símbolos
de algum conjunto gamma, digamos,
e elas satisfazem a
mesma condição de antes, que é que somam
à matriz identidade, então temos uma medição projetiva
que funciona exatamente
da mesma maneira que antes.
A única diferença aqui é que estamos permitindo
os resultados da medição serem elementos desse conjunto gamma em vez dos inteiros de um a M.
Para nosso primeiro exemplo de
uma medição projetiva, vamos observar que
as medições de base padrão são medições projetivas.
Neste caso, o conjunto de
resultados da medição é o mesmo que o conjunto de estados clássicos de qualquer sistema que está sendo medido.
E o conjunto de projeções
que descreve a medição é esta coleção aqui, assumindo que sigma é
o conjunto de estados clássicos
do nosso sistema. Essas são todas projeções
e se as somarmos, obtemos a matriz identidade, então é uma medição projetiva válida
Para ver como isso funciona em
um pouco mais de detalhe, vamos supor que temos
algum estado arbitrário escrito na forma
que você vê aqui.
A probabilidade para a
medição produzir o resultado A, de acordo com a descrição
de há um momento, é este valor aqui,
que é igual ao
valor absoluto ao quadrado da entrada correspondente
do vetor Psi, que é o que esperamos.
Condicionado ao resultado ser A, o estado do sistema se torna este, novamente de acordo com a
descrição de há um momento.
Se simplificarmos, não obtemos
exatamente o estado que esperamos, que é Ket A.
Em vez disso, obtemos Ket A
multiplicado por um escalar, e especificamente, este é um escalar com
valor absoluto igual a um,
então é um número complexo
no círculo unitário.
Isso é chamado de fase global e vamos discutir fases globais em breve, mas por enquanto, em suma, este
estado é equivalente a Ket A.
Essa fase global não
tem nenhuma significância e veremos o porquê
quando chegarmos à discussão sobre fases globais.
Então deixando de lado essa questão das fases globais, que vamos discutir em apenas um momento, vemos que as medições de base padrão
são de fato medições projetivas. Para outro exemplo, que é realmente uma extensão
do exemplo anterior,
se realizamos uma medição de base padrão
em um sistema X e não fazemos nada com um sistema Y, como discutimos
na aula anterior,
é completamente equivalente
a medir o sistema X, Y.
Com esta medição projetiva
aqui.
Temos essas projeções correspondendo aos estados clássicos de X e estamos tensorando com a identidade em Y
o que reflete o fato de que
não estamos fazendo nada com Y.
A descrição de como
as medições projetivas funcionam em geral nos diz
o que acontece neste exemplo, e vou deixar que você
verifique que de fato é
completamente equivalente ao que discutimos na aula anterior.
Isso é muito bom porque esta descrição de medição projetiva é mais limpa de certa forma e vemos que ela se encaixa em
esta imagem mais geral.
Aqui está mais um exemplo de
uma medição projetiva.
Este é uma medição de dois qubits.
Para esta medição
temos duas projeções e, portanto, dois resultados possíveis, que são zero e um.
As projeções são definidas
em termos dos estados Bell como você vê aqui.
A primeira projeção é
para o espaço gerado pelos três estados Bell simétricos e a segunda projeção é
para o espaço unidimensional
gerado pelo estado Psi-, que é o anti-simétrico, ou em outras palavras o
que é multiplicado
por um sinal de menos se
realizamos uma operação de swap nos dois qubits.
Veremos mais adiante na série por que esta é uma medição interessante.
Por enquanto, é apenas um exemplo
que se conecta com algo que vimos antes,
que é a base Bell.
Uma nota final sobre medições projetivas é que sempre que você tem
uma medição projetiva, você sempre pode implementar essa medição
usando operações unitárias e
medições de base padrão.
Para este exemplo específico de
uma medição, por exemplo, podemos construir um circuit quântico que implementa a medição
como você vê aqui.
Imaginamos que os dois
qubits superiores são os qubits que estamos medindo com
esta medição projetiva e o que podemos fazer é
introduzir um novo qubit
que começa inicializado
ao estado zero. Realizamos um gate Hadamard
seguido de um gate Fredkin, seguido de outro gate Hadamard,
e se medirmos este qubit inferior usando uma medição de base padrão, o efeito será exatamente o mesmo que se tivéssemos medido os dois qubits superiores
com a medição projetiva
deste exemplo.
Obteremos exatamente as mesmas probabilidades para os dois resultados e o efeito que a medição tem nos dois qubits superiores
será o mesmo também.
Isso não é nada óbvio. É necessária uma análise para ver isso e essa análise não é mostrada aqui.
Como já sugeri, vamos dar uma olhada mais detalhada em
esta medição específica em uma aula posterior e por enquanto
é apenas um exemplo.
O ponto importante a reter é que algo como
isso é sempre possível para qualquer medição projetiva, portanto na verdade não ganhamos
nenhuma capacidade adicional
introduzindo medições projetivas, mas é um conceito muito útil e frequentemente vamos falar de medições projetivas
à medida que continuamos na série. A última parte desta aula é sobre algumas limitações importantes
da informação quântica
e o que podemos fazer com circuits quânticos.
A primeira limitação, que talvez não seja tanto uma limitação quanto uma degeneração, diz respeito à questão das fases globais
que mencionei há pouco. Aqui está a definição do que queremos dizer quando nos referimos a uma fase global.
Se temos dois vetores de estado
quântico, Psi e Phi, tais que um deles é
igual ao outro multiplicado por algum número complexo alpha,
então dizemos que os estados
diferem por uma fase global ou alternativamente que são equivalentes a menos de uma fase global.
Note que porque vetores de estado quântico têm norma euclidiana igual a um, a única maneira pela qual esta
equação pode ser verdadeira
é se o valor absoluto
desse número complexo for igual a um, então alpha
deve estar no círculo unitário.
Vamos imaginar que temos
dois estados quânticos assim que diferem por uma fase global e suponha que medimos o estado Phi
com uma medição de base padrão.
A probabilidade de obter qualquer resultado A é dada por esta expressão aqui, e se substituirmos
alpha vezes Psi por Phi,
o que podemos fazer porque estamos
assumindo que são iguais, obtemos esta probabilidade.
E se simplificarmos usando o fato de que alpha está no
círculo unitário complexo, obtemos esta probabilidade.
Lembre-se de que esta é a probabilidade de que medir Phi dê o resultado A, mas agora vemos que
esta é exatamente a mesma que a probabilidade de que medir
Psi dê o resultado A,
então absolutamente
não há diferença alguma nas probabilidades de diferentes resultados para os dois estados.
Um argumento semelhante nos diz de forma mais geral que para qualquer medição projetiva, as probabilidades são novamente idênticas.
Então medindo não conseguimos
distinguir entre dois estados que
diferem por uma fase global, mesmo em sentido estatístico.
Finalmente, se aplicarmos qualquer operação unitária ao estado Phi, então novamente por substituição, o que obteremos é exatamente
o mesmo número complexo alpha
multiplicado pelo que obteríamos aplicando a mesma operação unitária
ao estado Psi.
Então os dois estados ainda vão
diferir por uma fase global.
A conclusão é que os dois estados são completamente indistinguíveis, então realmente não há
diferença entre eles
em termos do que poderíamos
possivelmente aprender sobre eles realizando operações unitárias e medições, e por essa razão,
consideramos esses dois
estados como equivalentes ou, se preferir, que esses são apenas dois possivelmente diferentes
representações vetoriais do
mesmo estado quântico.
Como disse no
início da discussão, é basicamente degeneração
em como estados quânticos são descritos por vetores de estado quântico.
De qualquer forma, o que isso significa é que podemos
simplesmente ignorar as fases globais assim como fizemos efetivamente ao descrever as medições de base padrão
como medições projetivas. Aliás, essa degeneração só acontece na descrição simplificada
da informação quântica.
Quando descrevemos estados
quânticos usando matrizes de densidade, como faremos na
terceira unidade da série, teremos uma representação matricial única
para cada estado quântico. A questão das fases globais
simplesmente não surge na descrição geral
da informação quântica.
É mais um aspecto atraente
da descrição geral da informação quântica,
ao qual continuo aludindo, mas de qualquer forma, as fases globais não nos incomodarão
porque podemos simplesmente exercer
nossa liberdade de ignorá-las.
Aqui está um exemplo muito rápido
apenas para ter certeza de que a noção de fase global está clara.
Se temos um estado menos, e menos um vezes um estado menos, então esses dois estados
diferem por uma fase global, e em particular temos
alpha igual a menos um.
Por outro lado, se temos um estado mais e um estado menos, então não temos dois estados
que diferem por uma fase global.
Esses são vetores ortogonais, então são linearmente independentes.
Dizer que dois vetores de estado quântico diferem por uma fase global
é equivalente a dizer que os vetores são linearmente dependentes,
então certamente esses vetores
não diferem por uma fase global.
É verdade que a única diferença é que este sinal de mais
vira este sinal de menos, mas isso é o que chamamos de diferença de fase relativa.
Isso é diferente de uma fase global porque não estamos
multiplicando o vetor inteiro por um número complexo.
E isso é consistente com o fato de que podemos distinguir entre esses estados, em particular, se
aplicarmos uma operação Hadamard
e depois medirmos, veremos zero se o
estado era um estado mais e um se o estado era um estado menos.
A próxima limitação da informação quântica que veremos nesta aula
é o teorema da não-clonagem.
Aqui está um enunciado do
teorema da não-clonagem e este enunciado específico
do teorema é bastante concreto e específico,
o que tornará mais fácil falar sobre isso. Há outras formas mais gerais de formular o teorema da não-clonagem,
mas vamos nos concentrar neste por agora.
Assumimos que temos dois sistemas X e Y que têm o mesmo conjunto de estados clássicos.
que consiste nos
inteiros de zero a D-1 onde D é pelo menos dois.
Na verdade não é importante quais nomes os estados clássicos têm, mas escolhendo esses nomes vai ajudar a manter as coisas simples.
O mais importante
aqui é que há pelo menos dois estados clássicos diferentes, então em outras palavras, não estamos nos preocupando com o
caso trivial e desinteressante
onde só temos um estado clássico.
O que o teorema diz é que não há operação unitária U que possamos aplicar a X, Y para que se inicializarmos
Y ao estado zero,
efetivamente copiamos ou clonamos
estados quânticos arbitrários de X.
Se olharmos para esta
expressão aqui em isolamento, o que ela diz é que para todas as escolhas de um vetor de estado quântico Psi de X,
aplicar U a Psi tensorado
com o estado zero, nos dá Psi tensor Psi, ou em outras palavras duas
cópias independentes de Psi,
então é o que significaria se pudéssemos clonar estados quânticos e o que o teorema diz é que isso não é possível.
Você pode pensar sobre isso
em termos de circuits e o que o teorema diz é que você nunca vai conseguir criar um gate ou um circuit
que funcione como você vê aqui.
Onde uma cópia do estado Psi entra junto com uma coleção
de qubits inicializados e duas cópias de Psi são produzidas.
Você pode fazer isso para certas
escolhas do estado Psi, mas nunca pode criar
um circuit que funcione desta forma para todo estado quântico Psi,
e é o que o teorema diz.
É bastante fácil provar
este teorema, na verdade, ele essencialmente se resume ao fato de que a transformação que estamos
procurando não é linear,
mas operações unitárias são
lineares, então simplesmente não pode funcionar.
Aqui está um argumento com um pouco mais de detalhe.
Suponha que temos uma operação unitária U que clona os estados de base padrão, Ket 0 e Ket um.
Sabemos que os estados clássicos zero e um devem pertencer ao nosso conjunto de estados clássicos porque D é pelo menos dois.
Mas isso significa pela linearidade
que se X estiver em um estado mais, que podemos escrever assim,
então o resultado é esta combinação linear desses dois estados aqui.
No entanto, esse não é o comportamento correto. O requisito em U é que U clona o estado mais,
o que significa que precisamos
ter esta equação aqui sendo satisfeita.
Esses dois estados não são
iguais e então não funciona e é tudo isso.
Apenas algumas observações adicionais
sobre o teorema da não-clonagem.
Primeiro, este enunciado do
teorema da não-clonagem é absoluto em certo sentido.
Ele simplesmente diz que uma operação unitária U que funciona exatamente
assim não existe.
Então você pode perguntar se
existe ou não uma operação unitária U que
faz isso aproximadamente com relação a alguma maneira de descrever
uma aproximação ao enunciado. Há diferentes
noções de aproximação nas quais alguém pode estar interessado
e veremos algumas
delas na terceira unidade da série, mas para essas diferentes
noções de aproximação,
há enunciados quantitativos
do teorema da não-clonagem que colocam fortes limites em quão bem você pode clonar aproximadamente.
Uma segunda observação é que copiar ou clonar estados de base padrão certamente
é possível.
Por exemplo, um gate Controlled NOT copia os estados de base padrão de um qubit.
Isso não contradiz
o teorema da não-clonagem. O ponto é que clonar no sentido do teorema da não-clonagem requer
que isso funcione não apenas
para estados de base padrão
mas para todos os estados.
Um gate Controlled NOT
certamente não clona um estado mais, por exemplo.
E finalmente, vale a pena destacar que também há um teorema da não-clonagem para
estados probabilísticos.
É simplesmente algo
que as pessoas não discutem ou se importam.
Se alguém escolher aleatoriamente
um bit, por exemplo, de alguma maneira arbitrária de
atribuir probabilidades aos dois valores e
então te passar esse bit,
claro que não há maneira de você obter duas amostras independentes
desse bit aleatório.
Você simplesmente não sabe quais
são as probabilidades.
Você pode copiar o bit assim como um gate Controlled NOT
copia estados de base padrão, mas isso não é a mesma coisa que clonar o estado probabilístico.
Você simplesmente não tem informação suficiente para fazer isso. Qualquer bit aleatório que te foi dado não te diz quais
eram as probabilidades.
É apenas um bit.
A impossibilidade de clonar
um estado probabilístico segue exatamente o mesmo raciocínio que no contexto quântico.
Clonar é um processo não linear, ao passo que operações probabilísticas, assim como operações unitárias, são lineares.
De qualquer forma, não é surpreendente
que não possamos clonar um estado probabilístico e
de alguma forma não é tão interessante quanto o fato de que não podemos
clonar um estado quântico,
mas o ponto é simplesmente observar que isso não é um fenômeno exclusivamente
quântico.
A limitação final
da informação quântica que vamos discutir nesta aula é que não é possível discriminar perfeitamente
dois estados quânticos que não são ortogonais.
Outra maneira de dizer isso
é que se dois estados quânticos podem ser perfeitamente discriminados, então eles têm que ser ortogonais.
O que queremos dizer quando nos referimos
a uma discriminação perfeita de dois estados quânticos, Psi e Phi, é que há alguma
maneira de distingui-los
sem qualquer chance de erro.
Em termos do modelo de circuit quântico, podemos expressar isso como você
vê aqui na tela.
Temos alguma operação unitária U, que poderia ser implementada
como um circuit quântico ou poderíamos simplesmente pensar sobre U abstratamente
como uma operação unitária
e a entrada de U é o estado Psi ou o estado Phi
junto com um monte de qubits inicializados, que você pode pensar como qubits de espaço de trabalho que de alguma forma assistem neste
processo de discriminação.
Depois que U é aplicado, o qubit superior é medido com relação a uma medição de base padrão e aqui está a parte da discriminação perfeita.
Se o estado de entrada era Psi, então a medição deve
dar o resultado zero, 100% das vezes, e se
o estado de entrada era Phi,
então a medição deve
dar o resultado um, novamente com 100% de chance.
Não é importante qual é o
estado desses outros qubits depois que U foi aplicado.
Tudo o que importa é esse único bit que obtemos da medição porque é esse bit que nos diz com qual dos dois estados começamos.
Para algumas escolhas de estados Psi e Phi, será possível realizar uma discriminação perfeita como
essa e para outras não será.
E o que vamos observar é que
se for possível fazer isso, então Psi e Phi têm
que ser estados ortogonais
e isso significa que se Phi e
Psi não são ortogonais, você não pode discriminá-los perfeitamente.
Então vamos ver por que uma discriminação perfeita implica ortogonalidade.
Vamos começar escrevendo duas equações que expressam o que esses
dois diagramas expressam.
Se pensarmos sobre o estado quântico que obtemos depois de aplicar U a
um monte de qubits inicializados junto com o estado Psi,
vemos que ele tem que
ter esta forma aqui, onde Pi zero é algum vetor de estado quântico representando o estado
de todos esses qubits
exceto o superior. Não temos nenhuma informação
sobre esse estado quântico Pi zero, pode ser qualquer coisa,
mas sabemos que o estado inteiro
tem que se parecer com isso porque é a única
maneira pela qual a medição é garantida de dar o
resultado zero, 100% das vezes.
E temos uma equação análoga para a segunda.
Desta vez, o qubit superior
tem que estar no estado um e, semelhante a Pi zero, o
estado Pi um pode ser qualquer coisa.
E além de não termos
nenhuma informação sobre Pi um, também não sabemos nada
sobre a relação entre Pi zero e Pi um.
Por tudo que sabemos, esses são apenas dois
estados quânticos arbitrários.
O que podemos fazer em seguida é
multiplicar ambos os lados dessas equações
em ambos os lados por U dagger, ou seja, a transposta conjugada de U.
E se fizermos isso, obtemos as duas equações
que você vê aqui.
Estamos usando o fato de que U dagger vezes U é a matriz identidade.
É por isso que não vemos U ou U dagger no lado esquerdo de nenhuma das equações.
E agora podemos considerar o produto interno entre Psi e Phi.
É o mesmo que o produto interno
de Psi e Phi multiplicado pelo produto interno
do estado L zero com ele mesmo
porque o produto interno de
qualquer estado com ele mesmo é um e isso inclui o estado L zero.
E agora se olharmos para nossas duas equações, vemos que esta expressão aqui é igual ao produto interno dos vetores
representados pelas duas equações. E em particular é o produto interno entre os lados
esquerdo
dessas equações.
Então podemos igualmente bem
expressar esse produto interno como o produto interno dos vetores representados pelos lados direitos dessas equações,
porque o lado esquerdo é
igual ao lado direito para ambas as equações.
Então obtemos esta expressão aqui, que é o produto interno
dos dois lados direitos das equações ou equivalentemente,
é a transposta conjugada do primeiro multiplicada pelo segundo.
U vezes U dagger é igual
à matriz identidade, porque U é unitária e então desaparece.
E podemos simplificar um pouco para obter o produto de
esses produtos internos.
Lembre-se de que não sabemos nada sobre a relação
entre Pi zero e Pi um, então não sabemos qual é
seu produto interno.
Isso é um mistério para nós. Mas seja lá o que for, estamos multiplicando pelo produto interno de Ket 0 e Ket um, que é zero.
Então o resultado final é que
obtemos o valor zero, mas é isso que queríamos mostrar, o produto interno entre
Psi e Phi é igual a zero.
Então os dois estados são ortogonais.
Então não perca tempo tentando
discriminar perfeitamente dois estados quânticos não ortogonais, simplesmente não tem como fazer isso.
Há uma conversa para o
enunciado que acabamos de provar, que é que estados quânticos ortogonais sempre podem ser perfeitamente discriminados,
e isso não é muito difícil de
ver se usarmos um fato que mencionei anteriormente na aula.
Especificamente, se Psi e
Phi são estados ortogonais, então uma coisa que podemos fazer é escolher qualquer matriz unitária U
cujas primeiras duas colunas
são os dois estados.
Sabemos que sempre é
possível fazer isso e não importa
para fins dessa tarefa exatamente como essa matriz unitária é escolhida.
Tudo que é importante é que essas são as primeiras duas colunas.
Não precisamos de qubits adicionais. Se simplesmente aplicarmos U aos
dois estados possíveis, então obteremos esses
dois resultados possíveis.
E se medirmos o qubit mais ao topo, que lembre-se é o qubit mais à direita, então obteremos zero ou um
dependendo de qual estado começamos.
Alternativamente, podemos considerar
uma medição projetiva com resultados zero e um
definida como você vê aqui.
Neste caso, a medição
na verdade só depende de Psi.
Esta medição discrimina perfeitamente Psi de qualquer estado que seja ortogonal a Psi.
Se medirmos Psi com relação a esta medição projetiva, então obteremos o resultado
zero com probabilidade um como estas equações revelam.
E para qualquer estado Phi
que é ortogonal a Psi, obteremos o resultado
um com probabilidade um.
Não vou passar pelos
detalhes desses cálculos, mas se estiver interessado, encorajo que você passe
pelos detalhes por conta própria.
E esse é o fim da aula três. Cobrimos muito material nesta aula, incluindo circuits quânticos,
produtos internos e ortonormalidade, projeções e medições projetivas, o fato de que as fases globais não importam,
o teorema da não-clonagem, e o fato de que estados não ortogonais não podem ser perfeitamente discriminados enquanto estados ortogonais podem.
Espero que você se junte a mim para
a quarta aula em breve, que é a última aula na
primeira unidade da série.
Na quarta aula, vamos falar sobre três
exemplos muito importantes: teleportação, codificação superdensa,
e a desigualdade CHSH ou jogo CHSH como às vezes é descrita.
Até a próxima,